history
history
dave chappelle attacked on stage tuesday
night
the 48 year old comedian was tackled
mid-set as he performed at the los
angeles hollywood bowl as part of the
netflix is a joke festival the los
angeles police department confirms to et
that they responded to an incident
around 10 40 pm after the suspect
identified as 23 year old isaiah lee
jumped on stage armed with a handgun
replica the suspect was detained and
booked on 30 thousand dollars bail
[Music]
after the incident fans caught this
video of the suspect on a stretcher
outside of the venue
an eyewitness tells et that chappelle
did a good job at dodging the actual
tackle adding that before anyone could
understand what was happening security
was able to remove the suspect from the
stage quote there were a few moments
where the audience were confused what
was going to happen afterwards
well that's when the comedian's good
friend chris rock who performed at the
festival before chappelle returned to
the stage to make a joke naturally
asking
was that will smith
[Applause]
of course that was a reference to when
smith slapped rock during the 2022
oscars after he made a joke about the
oscar winner's wife jada pinkett smith
and chappelle he handled the whole thing
like a boss
i've been doing this 35 years
i just stopped in the backstage
always wanted to do that
everybody compose yourselves
i wanted us
to be a peaceful moment and
i'm sure now it is
the funny man even gave props to his
friend jamie foxx who he said was right
by his side ready to defend him
shout out to jamie foxx by the way
whenever you're in trouble
jamie foxx would show up in the sharon's
hat
i thought that was part of the show i
don't know
i
i grabbed the back of his head his hair
was spongy
dormant
and fox he gave that love right back to
his pal
listen i just want to say man i've had
an incredible time this man is an
absolute genius we got to make sure we
protect him at all times man this is
what it's about for every comedian that
comes out here man this means everything
man you're a genius you're a legend i
enjoy myself thoroughly and we're not
gonna let nothing happen to you that's
right
[Music]
you